the Joe Rogan experience my grandma she
didn't like my dad oh no he didn't like
her neither really
he said it's right here you say hey call
your grandma up in the winter he said go
call your bubby up and tell her to come
into the house and visit you kids and
tell her to walk down the side where the
icicles are so I could crawl out on the
roof and [ __ ] a hammer and it will
fall down and pierce through her brain
whoa you heard this kind of [ __ ] when
you were a kid yeah it was all about
that was hilarious huh what was wrong
with your grandma that he was so upset
her this is so I'm assuming that was his
wife's mom yeah his wife's mom oh she
was a [ __ ]
there was no big thing on her boss she
uh she had big [ __ ] she owned her own
apartment house had 12 units she
controlled everyone's lives who lived
within there whoa
nobody would dare bark you know I like
ladies like that one I don't have to be
under their thumb yeah you know if I
like he doesn't know them I think it's
fun she got a guy under her thumb this
was I want to write this as it to a
movie
Oh a brief one of her tenants was a guy
at war golf shirt she'd never seen that
before
she's seen like one-legged [ __ ] in an
army fatigues you know in America cuz
this was in the ghetto where she had her
apartment house and right by the bus
station there that's how I grew up but
uh you know oh yeah so he he's wearing
these golf shirts she's like Tyler what
shared thick Lithuanian accent dial our
waters in garbage I can't do it Gulf
sheds he's going to golfing it's a
classy guy you know
I see kinda guy classy customer so he
made the mistake of thinking she was a
warm person as many people make that
mistake with all Jewish women thinking
they're warm and loving people she
wasn't well she was but there was a dark
side there to die yeah so he tells her
that he's a fugitive oh oh and that was
her favorite show at the time the
fugitive the one with the guy had one
leg or something one arm when I'm right
the fugitive that was ourselves so he
told her tell her he was a fugitoid she
turn him in to the cops nope she moved
him underneath her her apartment under I
mean she was under and she put him above
and she hooked up a bell on a rope that
went into his kitchen in her bed and if
she goes ding ding ding he had a
government run and give her a [ __ ] no
no she was a Jewish woman are you
kidding my garbage came to the street I
was hoping it was a positive ha ha time
for you to cut the grass I need you to
go fix the toilet number 8 well once she
finds out he's a fugitive he's [ __ ]
yeah yeah so she goes so anyway we asked
kids was there he falls in love with my
mother who looked like Elizabeth Taylor
and so my mom you know he's thinking
that all her daughter she'll help me out
she's working me to death this old bag
so my mom been that way too she gets in
on it I need you to come over cut my
grass and pretty soon his job was to sit
at our dinner table between her and my
dad and go hell and this is the most
delicious roast I've ever tasted in my
life that was his job yeah and my dad
just sitting here like yeah it's good
she's like I make my husband jealous too
so it became psycho and it goes on and
on that's 12 but at the end of that
summer he turned herself in couldn't do
it anymore
it was worse being into her prison yeah
the two of them oh my god
then they got in a family fight and tore
at each other's hair over this guy
whoa that was my upbringing good
everything's funny on how your mom
looked like Elizabeth Taylor yeah she
had a waist god damn it I wished I had a
waist I got my dad's body he was a
football player and they called him
Jerry bar the boy built like a barrel
barrel buddy I totally got it and so I
thought why I was in Hollywood I would
get like a girl body with some ass
cheeks and a waist
whoo so I'm still trying to work on that
well you mean like surgery wise don't ya
like the Kardashian family god I
idolized them they're out here you know
they are out here yeah yes I've seen
them have you ever looked at their ass
right not up not tight pull that
microphone I have that's a problem with
no headphones forget I'm sorry yeah yeah
I've seen their ass firsthand in Beverly
Hills I was I was through I never saw
anything so incredible in my life is
like the eighth wonder of the world
it was completely up there was no sag
whatsoever what I'm like see I just had
like a crack in my back I never had I
was asked us in an ask based economy and
that was my problem and I was like oh my
god but be like you're never gonna get
in my parents both you're never gonna
get a husband because you're too fat and
you have you know thank you
you have no ass you have no waist you
need to work out you know whatever and
you have a big mouth and no guy will
ever like that obviously he was wrong
well I proved him wrong three [ __ ]
[Applause]